the halo truss became world-renowned
when princess diana walked through a
minefield in angola
her son prince harry trodden her
footsteps on a visit to the country in
2019.
these projects are now under threat
the halo trust has been clearing minds
in northwest syria
left by syrian government forces and
islamic state
but the charity has lost its eu funding
since brexit
and has missed out on uk funding after
the government cut the aid budget
it will now stop work and pull out of
syria
our work really has something that the
british public can buy into
they can understand what we're doing you
can come and visit the minefield
see the impact that it has and blow up
the landmine
our work is incredibly good value for
money it seems to me that
someone needs to fund this work and
instead of bickering over budgets
we should be thinking about the people
who are actually suffering as a result
of this board
the uk aid budget was reduced last year
from 0.7
of gross national income to 0.5 percent
because of the financial cost of the
covered pandemic that's
small in percentage terms but massive in
impact on the ground
and not just in syria in a statement the
foreign office conceded that
the seismic impact of the kova 19
pandemic on the uk economy
has forced us to take tough but
necessary decisions
including temporarily reducing the
overall amount we spend on aid
that's meant that the uk has reduced the
amount it is sending to yemen
one of the world's worst humanitarian
crises
and british aid spending in libya the
sahel and afghanistan is also expected
to fall
these aid cuts are gonna cost lives it's
gonna
impact in some of the most fragile
places
in the world so places like syria
a 10-year war with 25 million people
not having access to basic services
the government says that the aid cut is
temporary
and that the budget will rise again when
the fiscal situation allows
there's no guarantee when that might be
though already
only a few months after the cut was
announced the consequences
are being felt around the world aleister
bunker sky news